[Musique]
ça lui était un bon ami
heureux de vous retrouver
alors les terriens de ce soir sont
pascal obispo
jean-pascal bonsoir vous êtes ici ce
soir pour un livre intitulé la méthode
obispo pour draguer les filles dans
lequel vous révéler que la technique
infaillible seller composer un album on
fabrique
autres terriens également avec nous ce
soir bruno le roux
non là évitez ps de seine-saint-denis
président du groupe ps à l'assemblée
nationale lors cette députée du 9-3 quoi
ici le 9-3 dans la place tranquille du
bruit pour le député du 9 3
c'est marrant moi les mecs du 9-3 je les
voyais pas comme ça on se fait des idées
parfois mais j'y suis pas simplement
élus j'y suis né j'y ai grandin mais
j'ai fait toutes mes études j habite
vous mettez des survêt blanc pour aller
sur des marchés le dimanche matin
non mais je suis pas sur les marchés le
dimanche matin quand je suis la semaine
alors une terrienne avec nous ce soir
c'est tout si
le raphia tout vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et chroniqueuse dans
l'émission le grand vide sur direct 8 et
vous êtes ici pour répondre à deux
questions que tout le monde vous pose
tout le temps non vous n'êtes pas la
soeur d'omar sy non vous n'êtes pas
libre à dîner ce soir
en p3b le zapping et gaspard push
nous accueillerons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir daniel tammet
est autiste asperger élu parmi les 100 g
mi vivant et auteur de best-sellers
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens et le groupe reggae gréement de
fortune
[Musique]
alors pascal obispo re bonsoir 30 ans de
musique 20 ans de carrière 4 millions
d'albums vendus pour fêter ça vous
sortez un best of intitulé millésime
alors avec tout vos tubes c'est
incroyable ça fait quoi d'être l'un des
derniers chanteurs français avoir eu
assez de tubes pour faire un best of
en fait je me suis pas rendu compte au
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment de faire la
compilation ouais je sais pas faire
beaucoup de choses en fait un peu et je
me sens un peu inutile dans la vie
à part à part faire des albums pour pour
séduire les
ya des super chansons à moi j'ai acheté
le best of de dany brillant par exemple
il y avait douze fois suzette
noms qui font les compilations au bout
de deux albums très lourd elle attendait
un petit peu pour avoir avalé les
chansons dessus on écoute à quoi ça
ressemble ici
s'il est un choix
une fois
hélas
rien
c'est déjà
[Musique]
tu es
je suis
[Musique]
et
g
trop long un nom
[Musique]
des
alors gare à une y avait une terrasse
tout est à vendre et stuff c'est ça
le sommet
[Musique]
et
jusqu'à
mais tu
g
ben moi qui chante non
parce que je ne souhaite pas non mais
c'est le jeu des bleus sous le soleil
c'est énorme arrivé en plus générique ça
m'a permis de sama pape ça m'a pas mal
aidé au début une fois j'ai pu acheter
un synthétiseur avec sar est composé de
six mois s'écoulent et alors il ya
quelques chansons mais on peut pas tout
les écouter sinon on parle pas voilà
mais ceci étant c'est peut-être pas plus
mal
quelques chansons que vous avez écrit
pour les autres
et
voir
mais sans reprendre
vers quatre ans
mais c'est là que je me suis très flatté
et méchant non
il
[Musique]
chocolat chaud
on s'arrête parce qu'un point
[Applaudissements]
quelle machine à tubes mais là ça c'est
nouveau versé chaque année le pib du
mali non
non mais je les racheter ah oui chacun
enfin c'est à dire quand même que je
dois beaucoup tout ce qui s'est passé
aussi aux auteurs avec qui j'ai besoin
c'est pas voilà à commencer par
commencer par lionel florence
zazie aussi j'ai beaucoup appris avec
zazie et aider à la dernière c'est avec
desigual manas wallace et j'aimais bien
aussi les fleurs du bien l'album en
hommage à victor hugo
et si on n'était pas prêts verts
alors sur le plan mélodique quand vous
avez beaucoup reproché limitée polnareff
mais vous au moins votre fils c'est le
veau de quoi
le sien c'est peut-être le mien aussi
vanté d'avoir séparé alors là c'est le
best-of si vous deviez sortir un worst
of c'est à dire les pires chansons de
d'obispo vous mettriez quad dans la
reprise de queen avec mimie mathy pour
les [ __ ]
ouais mais le problème c'est que
l'autopsié a bouffé aux gens on peut
faire est encore aux [ __ ] je sais
bien les [ __ ] parce que ça permet à
tout un tas de chanteurs de rester digne
en faisant moins concerts par an
exagère parce que quand même on en fait
on en fait sept ou huit ouais vous avez
longtemps été boycotté par les victoires
de la musique à partir de combien
millions d'albums on s'en fout de savoir
quand même j'ai une fois le prix du
public c'était sympa mais le métier non
l'histoire ils vont boire des coups à
chaque fois qu'il faut c'est école alors
les victoires vous en snober les médias
toujours un peu méprisé vous pensez que
c'était dû à quoi cette mauvaise image
que vous aviez une mauvaise image pense
que toutes les personnes qui ont eu du
succès rapidement on a tout subi un
petit peu le même sort à un moment donné
quand ça fonctionne pas il faut tirer
sur le pianiste en même temps vous a
tiré dessus qu'une seule fois la salle
on m'a attiré 6000 n'ont pas eu non non
non j'ai lu la cicatrice non c'était pas
celle là celle là c'était ainsi un
camion mais oui mais ça m'a permis de
bien sympathisé avec johnny voyez ce que
je suis arrivé sur son bateau j'avais
jamais le pansement way et au moins il
m'a pris pour un homme et je suis
quasiment une idole pour les rappeurs
sanaa s'en préoccupent active à ce que
veut dire
ça s'est passé à ajaccio le 28 juillet
1997 c'est quelle chanson qui avait
déplu il fait plus froid que ces
assassinats
alors le tireur a bénéficié de
circonstances atténuantes
le juge avait demandé à voir le concert
maintenant ça va mieux vous avez déclaré
je suis en train de me trouver pourquoi
ces lois ne sais pas ce que j'ai
composées pour plein de plein de gens et
j'ai tenté plein de choses différentes
au niveau vocal et au niveau de la
musique et voilà maintenant les chansons
que j'écris j'ai l'impression qu'elles
sont plus fidèle à ce que je suis voilà
vous allez la formule nascar vous avez
déclaré ma réussite c'est d'avoir donné
un sens à ma vie d'avoir transformé mes
larmes en diamants shane black diamond
ses bonnes idées alors on va passer à un
quiz qui s'appelle pascal obispo dans le
demande d'aller plutôt jouer vous d'eux
parce que mais il connaît c'est soit des
phrases de blaise pascal soignable ans
pascal de pascal obispo voilà pascal ou
obispo
attention bruno attention axelsson ça
après difficile à vivre avec l'espoir
est une vie qui en vaut bien d'autres
pascal obispo
obispo non pascal il écrit vachement
bien alors à force de se chercher
partout on risque de se perdre malgré
tout obispo la wii
par coeur le répertoire
peu de choses nous console parce que peu
de choses nous afflige pascale bravo
si on a plus important à vivre et de
vivre au jour le jour le temps c'est de
l'amour osisko
c'est être malheureux que de vouloir et
ne pouvoir obispo maintenant c'est parce
qu'arabes cercueil mais c'est bien rare
mais ça prouve quand même tu vois mais
c'est bien parce que j'ai choisi le choc
des trucs qui sont qui sont proches de
l'écriture de lionel voilà à mon avis
pour tous sur pascal web écoutons ce
autopompe congrès des gens n'y arrive
ça c'est une question de semaines ou de
taille
c'est vrai
l'imagination dispose de tout elle fait
la beauté la justice et le bonheur qui
est le tour du monde est ce qu'elles
valent ah oui
l'envi tascom les heurts
entre obispo
obispo
il faut chercher notre bonheur hors de
nous
pascal obispo pascal
ça marche bien et c'est là c'est le
cadeau la dernière on ne vit on ne meurt
qu'une fois et on a le temps de rien que
c'est déjà la fin talisman obispo mais
l'année
alors stéphane qui gagne
bruno le roux un dj pour bruno le roux
je voudrais dire que pascal obispo sera
en tournée dans toute la france dès le
mois de mars et à l'olympia le 11
octobre voilà c'est une interview
après la tuerie pour discuter
n'accueille de l'asthme a tout de suite
[Musique]
roman sur lequel remet en soirée car
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
pascal obispo
le bruit de l'eau
et d'un chat ou six
alors nous leur sommes en soir vous êtes
député ps de seine-saint-denis président
du groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale et avec michel sapin pierre
moscovici laurent fabius il fait partie
du courant chauffe du ps
devait n'est pas politique mais soyez
plus obligé de composer avec un bonnet
sur la tête la journée
alors brenon avec michel sapin le foll
le drian vous faites partie des
hollandais historique vous travaillez
avec françois hollande depuis plus de 20
ans et pourtant vous n'êtes pas ministre
pourquoi parce que j'avais choisi ouais
j'avais dit depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois que si l'on gagnait je voulais
présider le groupe à l'assemblée un on
est quand même dans une démocratie où
pour faire avancer les projets ya besoin
de l'assemblée il ya besoin d'une
majorité il ya besoin d'animer un groupe
c'est une responsabilité qui me plaisait
vraiment un choix une envie vous auriez
peut-être mieux fait d'être ministre
parce qu'en tant que président de groupe
vous avez dû faire avaler un certain
nombre de couleuvres à vos amis députés
alors on va prendre la liste d'abord le
report de la loi sur le vote des
étrangers
j'espère que ça sera pas reportée ça a
été reportée depuis 30 ans oui c'est
trop long vous avez été obligé de faire
avaler aussi l'abandon de la procréation
médicalement assistée pas du tout c'est
décalé deux mois simplement vraies alors
attendez moi j'ai voulu faire la pma
quand il y avait qu un seul texte pour
faire pression notamment sur le
gouvernement pour qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout maintenant il ya deux textes dont
un qui est plus sécuriser juridiquement
ben voila je préfère attendre deux mois
et avoir une vraie avancée
supplémentaire
ouais je reviendrai à l'or blanc avait
fait mais aussi la signature du traité
budgétaire européen sepa sepa évidence
non c'était dans les propositions de
françois hollande dans l'élection met
donc il fallait en passer par là
d'ailleurs vous avez vu tout les mois on
ne parle plus aujourd'hui très
européenne on a réussi à réguler et non
pas qu'on en soit sorti mais enfin
c'était devenu dans la moi c'est vrai
que ouais je crois que françois hollande
a fait bouger les choses la crèche il
vient d'en france c'est un râle un des
rares en france qu'on ait trouvé
alors vous leur avez faire dire à vos
amis députés une augmentation de la tva
vouloir les faire aller 20 milliards de
crédits pour les entreprises c'est une
révolution pour la gauche moi je veux
bien ceux qui à gauche me disent
toujours faire baisser le chômage mais
faut taper sur les patrons 20 il ya
quand même un milieu à trouver parce que
ce qui crée c'est bien c'est aujourd'hui
c'est aussi ceux qui sont des
entrepreneurs alors c'est vrai qu'à
beaucoup de gens à gauche qui se
demandent si françois hollande est
toujours de gauche il paraît qu'il a mis
un peu ce titre sur son bureau avec
marquez rappelle toi que de gauche c'est
vrai
tout cas j'ai pas vu le bureau depuis
longtemps mais il n'y a pas besoin de ça
on est assez nombreux quand il le faut a
rappelé que doivent être les mesures
dans belfort se mettre au boulot là il
faut quand même qu'ils faisaient un peu
des trucs de gauche mais a quand même
nom on y est on le fait pour ça depuis
six mois alors les voeux aux français
alors à huit minutes comment ça se fait
il y avait des valérie trierweiler qui
lui arrive le dîner les servir
rentrer à la maison
en même temps
c'était dans ce mois quand j'ai fini de
l'écouté j'ai eu l'impression qu'il
avait dit ce qu'il avait à dire au fait
qu'est ce qu'il a dit exactement
que l'année 2013 elle est dure et que la
fin de l'année 2013 c'était la
perspective de renversement de la can en
chômage ouais ça puisque mariage dans la
surface 3 vous croyez vraiment non mais
sérieusement après vraiment qu'on va
inverser la courbe du chômage avec lui
c'est terrible à dire bien 1500 cholet à
nouveau tous les jours tant qu est sûre
et d'un seul coup ça va partir en
autonome et vous croyez qu'on ne fait
rien en ce moment les partenaires
sociaux ont achevé une discussion qui
s'est bien conclu nous avons fait un
contrat de génération pour liées à
l'emploi des plus vieux l'emploi des
plus jeunes les emplois d'avenir pour ce
qui pend une plus éloignées en l'espace
de huit mois vous n'avez pas moins de
quatre dispositifs alors qu'en cinq ans
il n'a pas eu un seul bah voilà on
essaye d'agir pas vous avez déclaré le
cap du gouvernement est particulièrement
clair et ses formes
et oui je pense que le cap est clair le
cap de la justice le cadre de cette
efficacité économique que nous
recherchons le cap de ne pas opposer les
français les uns contre les autres on
peut faire des réformes de la discuter
nous opposer quand même un peu les
riches contre les pauvres 1 quand même
l'un a non on essaye de faire parce que
sarko c'était les habous cdh un nom
savez je crois pas que les riches
aujourd'hui malgré les mesures pour les
prix soient beaucoup moins riche ouais
en tout cas j'ai pas vu un riche qui est
venu à ma permanence pour vous dire
qu'ils n'arrivent plus à vivre donc bien
alors vous le connaissez bien françois
hollande ferait c'est vrai qui se teint
les cheveux non sérieux
je te jure non mais c'est vrai c'est moi
quand j'ai lu ça dans le gîte ue j'en
revenais pas comment un mec qui se teint
les cheveux peut ne pas mentir alors la
particularité que check vous avez raté
le début fait qu'on va jamais chez le
coiffeur ensemble oui je pense que je ne
sais pas moi je l'imaginé une fois par
mois avec ses papiers à lille sur la
tête en train de faire sa couleur
jamais vu de photo vient chez vous la
whey vient pas sur moi en tout cas c'est
sûr et sain f comme berlusconi
pour les cheveux
bien alors apps est aussi rebond soir
je peux je peux vous appeler habsheim ça
fait trop médicaments c'est ça vous
soigne mais ça va alors cette chef
d'entreprise vous avez fondé les centres
de beauté ethnicia qui sont devenus
depuis hapsatou sy il y en a 17
aujourd'hui qui emploie 150 personnes et
qui réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 6,7
millions d'euros c'est bien bravo
la question qu'on se pose c'est combien
faut-il de séance dans vos salons pour
devenir comme vous
ça faut demander à mon père et à ma mère
alors vous êtes également chroniqueuse
dans l'émission le grand huit sur d8 aux
côtés de laurence ferrari roselyne
bachelot audrey pulvar et elisabeth bost
alors pour ceux qui n'ont jamais vu
cette émission c'est les spice girls
inversion tenema avec lachenaud dans le
rôle de victoria beckham
bien un truc très nouveau dans cette
émission depuis la rentrée un truc
révolutionnaire c'est que vous êtes
autour d'une table fini le canapé
voilà on peut plus voir on a regardé
comme ça les missions vous croyez que la
table c'est la sio firent pour relancer
l'audience où il faudra en arriver à
roselyne bachelot qui explique la
fellation avec une banane
attendait elle fait tout roselyne
bachelot a elle est super reviennent à
la une pâte est incroyable alors quand
on vous voit regrette un petit peu de
pas être au chômage parce que l'émission
passe en 11 heures quoi donc si on veut
l'avoir évidemment elle repasse le soir
à 2 heures du matin et ça vous plaît pas
ce cas moi j'adore aussi mais j'adore ça
tout est génial c'est la grande
révélation de la démission mais je pense
que la révolte
alors vous êtes né à sèvres en 1981 père
sénégalais ouvriers mère mauritanienne
femme au foyer huit enfants
moi j'ai vécu la plus belle enfance que
soit on joue temps assez la misère quand
vous êtes fuite c'est compliqué je me
souviens d'après midi avec mes frères et
soeurs où je m'éclatais voilà si je
devais recommencer je recommencerai à
même si j'ai peur d'être seule parce que
tu toujours grandi au milieu d'une
fratrie c'est génial lancez votre père
qui vous a transmis la valeur du travail
pendant trente ans où l'avait vu se
lever tous les matins pour le smic jour
comptant toujours fier en fait de
subvenir à ses besoins sa famille mon
père ce pour moi c'est mon héros cc
c'est un type qui est quand même parti
maman du fin fond du sénégal pour offrir
à ses enfants la chance d'aller à
l'école juste pour ça je crache pas sur
ce qu'il a fait non cela alors à 12 ans
pledge être business woman ne vient pas
les mêmes rêves que les petites filles
de votre âge à 12 ans je t'ai la gamine
la plus riche de mon quartier ce qu'en
fait je m'occupais des personnes âgées
de mon immeuble ils me donnaient tous
une pièce est donc j'étais la plus riche
de mon âge la business model
et vous en fait profiter votre famille
vous acheter des fournitures pour vos
frères et soeurs ouais on bossait pour
pour vivre bien et on a bien vécu avec
l'argent des petits vieux avec l'argent
des petits vieux il vous le donner
d'argent ou laure pitti n'ont
alors plus en plus tard à 24 ans vous
ouvrez votre premier espace beauté
ethnicia sur l'île saint louis et pour
lancer la marque fait une super idée
vous trouver un slogan ce énorme que
vous marquez sur les t-shirts est nichée
arrive en france s'est retrouvée à une
cinquantaine de femmes avec des t-shirt
blanc écrit au marqueur ethnicia on a
débarqué chez cathy guetta venu fort
veut 5 dans son ancienne boîte de nuit
et on a mis partout des flyers ethnicia
arrive en france tout le monde croyait
que ça arrive et des états unis ça
venait de ma tête c'est
très bonne idée
alors aujourd'hui vous avez des demandes
du sénégal du bénin du nigeria du maroc
des filières milliards d'eur c'est pas
ça me permettra de fait de payer un peu
plus d'impôts en france
j'avais pas faire l'exil fiscal
annoncé pour l'instant en tout cas j'ai
pas suffisamment d'argent pour les plans
pour partir
alors on passe maintenant à l'actualité
de la semaine on va reparler évidemment
d'exil fiscal avec les vitaux de blacko
1 et c'est jean daniel lévy de
l'institut de sondage harris interactive
que nous retrouverons sur ce plateau
après le magnéto
quels acteurs sont depardieu à lui tout
seul il a organisé un spectacle qui a
éclipsé le reste de l'actualité par un
scénariste et un réalisateur pas besoin
de producteurs juste jg en impro totale
filmé par la meute des journalistes qui
le poursuivent alors pourquoi continuer
d'aller ou de cinéma quand le meilleur
acteur français traces gratos à la télé
tous les jours gérard depardieu gérard
depardieu gérard depardieu gérard
depardieu bon c'est vrai qu'au niveau du
scénario le feuilleton depardieu c'est
un peu n'importe quoi cette histoire de
stars françaises qui s'expatrie en
belgique sp traité de minable par le
premier ministre c'est pas très crédible
mais après quand la star va boire pas
des mires poutine qui lui accorde un
passeport russe en 24 heures là ça
devient carrément du foutage de gueule
et pendant qu'on y est pourquoi pas
imaginer depardieu déguisé en mode gic
qui deviendrait ministre de la culture
de mordovie c'est ça qui est pratique
avec la télé réalité même si l'histoire
est complètement invraisemblable on est
bien obligé d'y croire puisque c'est
censé être la réalité faut dire qu'au
cinéma si un producteur veut mettre
depardieu la fiche de son film voici un
gros chèque à gg candide pour les
journaux ça ne coûte rien d'être
depardieu en une au contraire ça
rapporte puisque ça fait grimper les
ventes
alors quand on peut avoir deux par deux
gratos pourquoi se gêner d'autant que
j'ai en fait des tonnes pour alimenter
le spectacle j'ai un passeport
foot qui est inquiétant c'est qu'il
semble avoir entraîné tout le monde dans
son délire vu la place occupée par
gérard depardieu aux informations on
dirait que les journalistes eux non plus
ne font plus trop la différence entre la
fiction et la réalité
voilà c'était les mythos de blacko un
mise en image de julien grave
jean daniel lévy bonsoir j'ai directeur
du département politique opinion chez
harris interactive bienvenue parmi les
outils alors la paire depardieu a donc
fait la une des news toute la semaine et
salut les terriens a voulu savoir ce
qu'en pensent les français en demandant
harris interactive un sondage sur le
sujet alors première question
estimez-vous que gérard depardieu a eu
raison ou a eu tort de prendre la
nationalité russe brune très
majoritairement tort pascal moi je
concilie ligne de fer cieux dans les
sondages tu rentres dans l'est ne se
prononcent pas bah oui
ça tout en moi je pense qu'il est libre
de faire ce qu'il veut mais il aurait pu
choisir un pays un peu plus fun
alors la réponse des français
gérard depardieu a eu raison 30% gérard
depardieu a eu tort 63% c'est vous quoi
ce chiffre j'en ai bien ça évoque deux
choses ça évoque déjà une vraie
évolution parce qu'on se rappelle qu' il
avait été question hamon qui prenne la
nationalité belge et là les français est
un peu plus partagés c'est à dire qu'ils
avaient la perception quasiment pour
moitié que la belgique n'est pas si
grave que ça ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec la russie ces deux chaussées un
exil fiscal et puis deux la légitimation
auger des français d'un régime que les
français vont relativement condamné lui
qui rit le français préfère quand même
plus le roi que le tsar aurait quand
même ouais je pense je pense que c'était
le coup de trop je pense qu'à un moment
donné on peut avoir des gestes d'humeur
les français sont capables de comprendre
les gestes d'humeur par rapport de
l'imposition par rapport et toujours ce
sentiment que toute façon d'être taxés
mais là je pense que c'était quand même
oui en même temps les chiens c'est
encore pire la russie pour vivre
comprend qu'il était
alors deuxième question quelle image
avez-vous de gérard depardieu
moi je brûle pas en un instant l'image
que j'avais avant j'ai été voir tous ces
films pour moi ça reste quelqu'un qui
est exceptionnel et un grand acteur donc
de belles images de lui c'est toujours
l'image kocher malgré sa motion d'accord
je pense qu'elle est toujours gros
yves-rené mal élevés
alors
réponse des français à la question
quelle image avez-vous de gérard
depardieu bonne 37% à ses mauvaises 31%
très mauvaise 26% donc si on ajoute à
ces mauvaises de très mauvaises ça fait
quand même 57 absolument ils ont les
poser la même question au moment du
débat justement de son départ en
belgique avait cinq points de plus de
français qui avait une bonne image de
gérard depardieu donc ce n'était pas
extrêmement bons et ça s'est dégradé ce
cas ces frappes on sait qu'il ya un vrai
clivage politique derrière gérard
depardieu pour faire vite la droite a
aujourd'hui une bonne image de gérard
depardieu et la gauche aujourd'hui est
assez critique a une mauvaise image de
gérard depardieu probablement justement
autour de cette perception que
aujourd'hui il faut que tout le monde
selon la gauche participent à l'effort
collective on sait aussi que depardieu
c'est un sacré soutien de sarkozy non
qui c'est ça aussi pour déstabiliser le
gouvernement en place donc
alors pardon pascal nom de famille se
bat non enfin j'allais dire parce que
c'est vrai que vous trouvez peut-être
neutre mais moi j'ai l'impression moi je
veux je ne sais pas que je m'engage pas
mais j'ai l'impression que quand on
parle de vous pour autre chose que ce
que
par la raison pour laquelle vous êtes
connu c'est à dire en règle générale la
les artistes c'est pour faire rêver des
gens les divertir c'est vrai que c'est
normal que ça affecte un petit peu
l'image que vous avez moi j'ai toujours
préféré est privilégiée enfin la musique
c'est pas que j'ai pas d'idée mais c'est
parce que justement je préfère rester
nommons dans mon donc dans mon chat ne
sort de l'ambiguïté qu'elles sont des
pans sais pas qui a dit ça mais c'est
bien pascal blaise pascal obispo alors
la troisième question c'est irez-vous
voir le prochain film et jaar depardieu
ces dérives que cette histoire handicap
sa carrière à votre avis bruno moi je
pense que j'irai voir et en même temps
je penserai à ce que chaque fois que
j'ai été voir des films de depardieu
j'ai vu des familles qui est à côté qui
faisait la queue et qui quelquefois se
privaient peut-être pour aller à nous
tous leurs enfants aussi nette c'est
qu'à un moment donné les fortunes qui
s'amassent quand on est un acteur de
6,99 en trop mais c'est parce qu'il ya
un public derrière et ce public il est
très majoritairement français en tout
cas il était français au début est ce
que c'est un bouc émissaire pour le
gouvernement qui fait pas grand chose en
ce moment ils sont ravis depardieu qui
est là donc ça y est on va taper dessus
ceux-ci aventure en garde non parce qu'à
pâques depardieu qui est parti quand je
vois dans les acteurs omar sy qui fait
la déclaration hier de dire moi j'ai été
le lot d'allocations familiales j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui de rembourser
une dette quand je paye des impôts je
suis content d'en payer ils sont pas
tous intelligents je me dis que c'est
bien une chose la coach
français
irez-vous voir le prochain film avec
gérard depardieu
oui 9%
non 32%
pas d'impact sur ma décision 56%
je crois le plus intéressant on est
véritablement en france dans un autre
pays ça se passerait pas comme ça c'est
à dire qu'en général parce qu'on
considère qu'une personne se comporte
mal elle doit le payer jusqu'au bout et
en aucun cas on ira lui apporter le
soutien dans les autres pays en dehors
de la france on considère que le boycott
peut fonctionner hélas aujourd'hui on a
les deux aspects c'est que d'un côté les
français sont critiqués en même temps
ils disent si c'est un bon film ce
monsieur màj rêve est donc j'ai pas
forcément envie de faire payer plus que
cela gérard depardieu alors ceci étant
la bonne hausse et 75% passe quand même
incroyable parce que c'est une mesure
que l'on doit improviser
cahuzac était pas au courant personnes
étaient au courant ils savent à lui
resté un peu comme un scotch quoi ça va
être un peu comme le bouclier fiscal de
sarkozy c'est 75% pascal a sorti ça fait
gagner à l'état 200 millions d'euros
julia se bat un tout petit peu plus mais
en tout cas c'est à ces années avec le
symbole eh oui mais les français
continuent toujours d'ailleurs quand on
les questionne sur cette mesure à dire
oui nous la voulons pas nous pensons
temps nous sommes dans la crise il doit
y avoir une mesure exceptionnelle après
si jamais celui qui a beaucoup vient me
voir en me disant j'y arrive plus
j'arrive plus à vivre aujourd'hui
j'essaye de faire quelque chose pour lui
mais je crois pas que ça soit le cas
dans des gobelets qui tue le rêve qu'ils
font c'est l'ambition que non c'est bien
de taxer les riches c'est bien de ce que
tout le monde participe effectivement
moi perso quand j'étais enfant que
j'étais jeune ce qui me faisait rêver
c'est de voir des gens qui ont réussi
que les belles voitures qui ont des
belles maisons ça me donnait envie
d'avoir la même chose et là c'est un peu
là la chasse aux sorcières on va tuer
les riches en bas tu laisses et pareil
pour la fiscalité aux entreprises cc
c'est un assassinat aussi d des
entreprises on l'a vu il ya eu mouvement
des pigeons et où je reviendrai pas
dessus mais c'est un moment c'est ça
devient un rack est une attention dès
lors du pacte de compétitivité de
l'entreprise pour l'heure c'est qu'à mon
avis tous ces politiques n'ont pas été
sur le terrain pour voir ce qu'était
vraiment une entreprise et quand vous
amuser à venir taxes et notamment par
exemple les plus values que vont faire
les investisseurs vous tuez
l'investissement non vous vous tuez
l'investissement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
trouvent plus d'investisseurs en france
parce qu'ils vont regarder en angleterre
mais bon vous savez gamme sur l'autre
mais met en place une banque publique
d'investissement justement pour faire en
sorte que les entrepreneurs puissent
trouver aujourd'hui des financements
sincèrement ça pour moi c'est s'est
excusé moi c'est un peu du blabla parce
qu'en fait on fait que que réutiliser de
l'argent et on réinjecte pas d'argent à
neuf dans cette économie verte ou
seulement neuf tout simplement sur les
entreprises quand vous dites à quelqu'un
je te prendre 60 % de plus-value
l'investisseur rival rival en angleterre
et en attendant il ya plein
d'entrepreneurs comme non justement on
prendra exactement exactement sur le
problème c'est pas gérard depardieu
parce que bon genre de partie de sa
fortune est fait c'est les jeunes qui
ont 20 ans 25 ans 30 ans et qui sortent
en angleterre qu'il parte au canada qui
partent aux états unis c'est ça qui est
terrible parce que c'est eux qui vont
créer de la richesse pour plus tard
c'est un gérard depardieu évidemment à
chaque époque on dit ça va plus
aujourd'hui donc on part à l'étranger
moi je m'aperçois que je retrouve
aujourd'hui plein de jeunes créateurs en
seine saint denis mais il ya des
jcc ya la théorie à la pratique ce dans
la pratique moi j'ai des investisseurs
comme d'autres entrepreneurs ont des
investisseurs qui m'ont dit si vous
délocalisez pas le siège social on on
réinjecte pas d'argent ça c'est la
réalité on en prend on touche des
allocations familiales effectivement
françon dont on ya les retraites y
revient à un système social qui est
formidable mais il faut pas non plus
aller sur le sur une politique fiscale
confiscatoire mais c'est pas possible il
revient de confiscatoire
mais rien de tout faire foirer france et
c'est pour ça qu'il est en phase avec le
système d'impôts en france il devrait
être progressif le problème c'est que
ces dernières années il n'était plus
progressif et ceux qui avaient le plus
étaient ceux qui arrivaient à se dégager
le plus fortement de l'impôt et ceux qui
paient les impôts à proportion de ce
qu'il gagnait c'était les plus faibles
c'était les ouvriers fêter les cadres
moyens confiscatoire on gagne 100 euros
pour les autres bon bref la tva et race
80 ont payé un salarié 15 ans nous en
prend 15 et reste 30 on achète les les
matières premières et tout ce qui reste
il nous en reste peut-être cinq en tant
qu'entrepreneur on se verse pas
forcément de salaire on passe souvent
des années a pas se payer un de salaire
est dans la galère il reste 5 euros sur
les 5 euros on va payer les impôts
société normale ensuite à titre
personnel sur ce que je me serais verser
gevers payer de l'impôt donc à la fin
j'ai travaillé pour quoi j'ai pas
confiscatoire sais pas non plus 14
salles du court et aidé vous avez créé
de l'emploi vous allez créer de la
richesse et les gens qui travaillent
donc
je vous avertis et si avec ça tout
devient russe au sein de votre peau et
bien on continue à discuter de
l'actualité de la semaine avec l'édito
de blacko 2
voilà des années que tous les sondages
réalisés sur le mariage gay donne à peu
près le même résultat environ 60% des
français y sont favorables
comme quoi le mariage gay ne fait plus
vraiment débat pourtant les opposants au
mariage pour tous ne désarment pas et
ils rêvent encore de faire prier
gouvernement après tout c'est déjà
arrivé en 1984 en tête la direction de
l'enseignement catholique en faveur de
la défense de l'enseignement privé un
million de français avaient alors
manifesté contre la suppression de
l'école privée résultat un mois plus
tard la loi était abrogée et pierre
mauroy quittait matignon à l'ump on rêve
donc de refaire le coup de 84 jean
françois copé se verrait bien prendre la
tête d'une manne géante pour obtenir la
suppression du mariage gay et la
démission de jean marc ayrault forcément
ça relancerait un peu sa carrière tous
les moyens républicains doivent être
utilisés sauf que les manifs de droite
ça ne marche pas à chaque fois en 99 par
exemple le rpr avait appelé à manifester
contre le pacte
or aujourd'hui le rpr a disparu tandis
que le pacs lui est toujours là est ce
que dans quinze ans ce ne sera pas la
même chose pour le mariage gay qui a
rentré dans les moeurs en tout cas
l'avis des chansons la question dépend
beaucoup de l'orage chez les moins de 25
ans on est pour à plus de 75% tandis que
chez les plus de 65 ans elle contraire
on est contre à plus de 60% alors en
s'opposant au mariage pour tous comme
elles s'étaient déjà opposés au pacs la
droite se lance à nouveau dans un combat
d'arrière-garde qu'elle risque de perdre
mais sachant que les plus de 60 ans ont
voté majoritairement sarkozy en 2012 ben
c'est difficile d'aller contre son
électorat
voilà c'était d'éviter de blacko deux
mises en images de julien gracq alors
irez vous manifester demain contre le
mariage homo - non non
moi je vois pas pourquoi on empêcherait
les jours d'être heureux si l'on y avait
pas de problème ah ben ça tout à moi je
n'irai pas manifester parce que je suis
pour le mariage vous êtes dans tout le
monde ici et pour sauver jean daniel qui
se prononce pas en tant que l'otan qui
sont d'ailleurs je me prononce le simple
puisqu'un peu bizarre c'est que ça un
genou il existe dans beaucoup de pays
européens 60 % des français sont pour
plus on est jeune plus on est pour donc
c'est la loi passera inéluctablement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continue à
palabrer parce qu'ils ont toujours une
fin dans la société il ya un fond qui
est encore un fonds homophobes ombre on
peut être contre le mariage aux mousses
en être homo saint pardoux le complément
ça je le comprends mais je vais me
demander des explications et le fait qu
on dépénalise l'homosexualité
aujourd'hui j'ai des gens qui m'en
parlent encore en me disant que ça a
précipité la société française là où
elle est aujourd'hui et donc je crois
que c'est ça l'évolution nous voulons
faire simplement ses maîtres le droit
parce que nous sommes dans une sauteuse
droit vous mais en accord le mariage
homo c'est un progrès un jeu bien
entendu dans l'égalité des droits dans
la sécurité juridique qui est donné
aujourd'hui à ceux qui vivent à ceux qui
élèvent des enfants bien entendu que ça
progresse quand même beaucoup plus clair
qu encore une fois que françois hollande
s'est pas sûrs si jean daniel merci
d'avoir été avec nous remercie beaucoup
voilà c'est tout
françois près d'un pull avec joseph
gaspard proust et notre amitié des
sénateurs ce soir daniel tammet autiste
asperger
son prix
non
à tous
e
[Musique]
bonsoir était rien romont soir les
terriens nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de pascal obispo
je bruno le roux
dax à toucy et nous accueillir notre
invité du samedi 20 heures ce soir
daniel tammet de bonsoir
or daniels est autiste asperger vous
avez été élu parmi les sans génie vivant
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs best
seller et vous publié le 17 janvier
l'éternité dans une heure aux éditions
les arènes on en reparle dans un instant
mais pour l'instant j'accueille gaspard
proust
[Applaudissements]
avoue gaspard pour elle est pas belle la
vie
cashman
[Applaudissements]
alors oui avant de présenter mes voeux
pour 2013 j'ai une pensée émue pour tous
les syriens qui se sont souhaité une
bonne santé et qu'ils n'ont peut-être
pas eu le temps de finir cette phrase
d'ailleurs je me demande mais cette
année pour la france c'est pas des voeux
qu'il faudrait présenter mais des
prières alors tout le monde dit que 2013
sera plus dur que 2012 ah bon c'est
possible c'est le passé mais non enfin
c'est une bonne année aux pauvres en
2013 qu'ils se rassurent ils vont se
sentir de moins en moins seuls et c'est
toujours moins dure comme ça hein la
pauvreté c'est comme la chaude pisse en
garnison quand tu es seul tu as honte
quand ai dit si tu la compare avec
celles des autres
voilà
faut positiver donc 2013 l'année de la
transition des emplois de l'industrie
vers ceux des services c'est quand même
pas rien sortir de la mine pour aller à
la une peut
quitter la lampe frontale pour le néon
de pôle emploi c'est et l'anpe c'est
qu'une étape 1 avant le rsa les restos
du coeur emmaüs jean marc morandini
est vraiment au pire il ya la mendicité
mais la mendicité c'est quoi ces c'est
du théâtre de rue avec une mise en scène
minimaliste
c'est vrai qu'il se passe pas grand
chose mais au moins il y a une vraie
transparence sur les subventions
en 2013 façon j'ai décidé de me calmer
je ne vais plus du tout tapé sur
l'exécutif un dupont et dupond c'est
fini je ne perds au holland sais je peux
plus rien alors c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas des flèches mais pour une
fois que dans ce pays on a le choix
entre deux noms pour appeler le soldat
inconnu
et dans la foulée j'aimerais présenter
mes voeux aux 75% qui passeront l'hiver
ah oui ça je suis sûr on aura bien les
75 % jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat sauf
que ça va pas concerner le taux
d'imposition mais le chiffre du chômage
alors comme quoi chez les socialistes si
on a l'intuition du chiffre on n'a pas
forcément la certitude de son objet
en tout cas je souhaite une bonne année
au conseil constitutionnel qui est
devenu le centre de planning familial du
ps 1 c c'est là où se font avorter
toutes les lois socialistes
on n'imaginait pas les membres les sages
en avorteurs m'enfin bon c'est comme ça
c'est la vie tout arrive non je vous
passe les détails ce qui arrivera dans
quatre ans à tout le monde le sait
réélection de sarko au premier tour
momification de liliane bettencourt
ouverture de son mausolée place de la
concorde
ce sera évidemment une catastrophe pour
le cinéma français je veux dire même si
depardieu va revenir vu sa grande
moralité torreton va sans doute quitter
la france et prendre un passeport
nord-coréen
[Rires]
et
tout le monde sait ce qui arrive si tard
et on quitte la france fin il n'y a plus
un film qui va se monter
pardon
2013 commence assez bien pour les
salariés de virgin oui ils vont pouvoir
partir au ski avant les autres
parce que chez virgin et oui on solde
aussi les employés ont forcément je me
suis précipité quand j'ai déjà repéré
une vendeuse pas mal
c'est mon côté salafistes atequacy dans
un magasin qui s'appelle virgin et
seront forcément toutes deux premières
manches
évidemment tout le monde c'est indigne
que virgin dépose le bilan fait ça il
était temps que ses ventes des cd des
dvd pourquoi pas des minitel et des
machines à écrire facile en fait virgin
megastore ce n'était pas un magasin mais
un musée des succès du 20e siècle
on peut de galéjades économique
alors ça fait scandale à sa réveiller
des consciences chez vous c'était c'est
terrible à 24 heures avant la fermeture
la ministre de la culture a émis une
hypothèse c'est peut-être à cause de la
concurrence du commerce en ligne
waouh et on est en 2013 filippetti
découvre amazon
formé à ce rythme je veux dire à ce
rythme dans un an et louvre un compte
itunes et dans deux ans elle arrive à
poster une vidéo sur facebook
bravo bravo réduit
je souhaite également une bonne année
2013 à la première manif de l'année
enfin première manif de laisser le le
machin contre mariage pour tous ou
bourse ou plus très bien ce espèce de
cgt de la sexualité normative là qui va
battre le pavé enfin le grand défilé
pour la pénétration des orifices
socialement acceptable
au
moins dans ce pays on a le sens des
priorités je me demande si ça va être
quoi les slogans puisqu'on vous dit que
c'est pas le bon trop
l'anus c'est que pour le bonus
voire des cathos défilé contre le
mariage c'est à peu près aussi crédible
que de voir des végétariens militer pour
l'abattage halal quoi sert
donc à la sexualité gay aura au moins un
mérite faire parler les cathos de la
leur ce qui leur arrive assez rarement
en temps en même temps un truc je vois
pas très bien pourquoi ils s'excitent au
sujet de la pma est fait pour fallait
pas retirer cette loi c'est très bien la
pm ainsi en plus qu'est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs la procréation médicalement
assistée c'est quoi c'est faire l'amour
avec en se faisant tenir le sexe par
michel cymes c'est ça le
moi je comprends pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
l'église et contre la procréation
médicalement assistée de la pma c'est
quoi c'est la procréation sur le péché
de l'acte en fait c'est l'église devrait
être pourquoi c'est une sorte de
d'éjaculer conception costumes
2013 je souhaite également que la presse
française sont un peu plus objective si
elle pouvait enfin reconnaître que
vladimir poutine est un démocrate doublé
d'un humaniste alors mais vous
connaissez beaucoup de présidents qui
naturalise d'un étranger en trois jours
2013 le printemps arabe qui a donné sa
première récolte un pas très
convaincante c'est un seul bizarre que
c'est un insolent tu plantes de la
démocratie pouce de la charia
ferait peut-être mieux planter de la
dictature aurait plus de chances de
retrouver de la démocratie quoi hein
il m'amène au sujet des décapitation en
arabie saoudite une transition naturelle
76 décapitation en 2012 en arabie
saoudite on s'y prend mal pour exporter
la démocratie fin dans ces pays là
peut-être que si on leur fournissait la
guillotine il ferait le lien avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je
sais pas
c'est plus intelligente profond mais
faut terminer par une bonne nouvelle
peut être jack lang qui a enfin trouvé
un point de chute l'institut du monde
arabe
ça prouve donc que les rumeurs sur le
poste de garde champêtre place des
vosges était fausse
puisqu'on vous dit que c'est les soldes
alors pas belle la vie
point vous pouvez suivre l'action de
l'émission et réagir sur twitter via le
compte les terriens et le hashtag slt on
passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20
[Musique]
derrière net rebond soir dont vous êtes
un autiste asperger ce que l'on appelle
communément un autistes savants et vous
possédez des dons exceptionnels en
calcul et dans l'apprentissage des
langues mais le plus exceptionnel si
vous êtes un des seuls à pouvoir faire
des allers retours entre notre monde et
le monde de l'autisme c'est pour ça que
les scientifiques vous surnomme la
pierre de rosette de l'autisme d'après
le nom de cette pierre qui a permis de
décrypter les hiéroglyphes alors j'ai
déjà publié deux livres vendu à un
million d'exemplaires et vous revenez
aujourd'hui avec l'éternité dans une
heure la poésie dénombre publié aux
éditions les arènes alors daniel vous
êtes né le 31 janvier 1979 à londres
père ouvrier maire secrétaire famille de
neuf enfants
alors jusqu'à l'âge de deux ans vous
êtes un enfant difficile très bruyant et
puis soudain vous devenez silencieux
vous commencé à développer les premiers
symptômes de l'autisme
mais à l'âge de 4 ans vous êtes secoué
par des crises d'épilepsie de plus en
plus grave vous manqué d'ailleurs d'en
mourir heureusement mon appel a eu le
bon réflexe parce que son père avait les
crises d'épilepsie également un temps
qu'elle a reconnu tout de suite
le problème et il m'a amené tout de
suite à l'hôpital et
l'épilepsie évidemment c'est un symptôme
courant chez les autistes méfiez-vous
l'épilepsie a eu un impact déterminant
sur la construction de votre cerveau
c'est à dire que certaines connexions
neuronales été endommagé et le cerveau
les à contourner et on a créé une
nouvelle voilà alors chez vous avec neuf
enfants évidemment il ya beaucoup de
bruit ce qui est une souffrance pour
vous vous vous réfugiez dans notre monde
peuplé de chiffres vous comptez vous
calculer si votre univers oui puis un
jour je découvre parce qu'à l'époque
avait pas de pros mois dans une partie
de notre très mauvaise n'ya pas du
cinéma pas du musée par de théâtre il y
avait mieux vaut taire je regarde les
livres partout partout avec les noms et
chaque livre avec son nom différent et
je me suis dit si je regarde je suis mon
temps je vais trouver le livre est mon
nom dessus et je vais découvrir
l'histoire de ma vie je vais revoir
qu'est ce qui va se passer mon avis ni
est bien ce que j'ai jamais trouvé ce
livre et c'était plus tard j'ai compris
fallait d'abord a écrit ce livre
voilà exactement c'est une idée à la
borgers à l'arrivée dans une
bibliothèque et chercher le livre qui
raconte votre vision assez
extraordinaire en un livre qui nous
intéresse c'est les dictionnaires les
encyclopédies et puis effectivement les
mots prennent un peu comme les chiffres
une couleur une forme une texture une
émotion et ses mots deviennent vos seuls
compagnons oui en fait c'est comme si
les mots prenez le relais un peu des
nombres mais je suis dans un univers
donc de ces combinaisons des maîtres
fort
la poésie
je découvre la fiction parce que c'est
pas évident pour quelqu'un qui est
spectre otis de comprendre la fiction et
tout ça dans le monde normal vous êtes
un peu un alien on peut le dire et vous
êtes très très sensibles par exemple
chez vous quand vous êtes petit quand
votre mère
monte l'escalier vous attendez son sont
pas et pour vous c'est une souffrance
une violence quoi oui parce que les
bruits qu'on c'est aléatoire je savais
pas qu est ce que c'est je n'arrivais
pas à mettre une émotion aux quelque
chose dessus alors à l'époque donc dans
les années 80 le syndrome asperger n'est
pas diagnostiquée donc on vous met à
l'école comme tout le monde c'est une
expérience extrêmement douloureuse pour
vous parce que vous êtes qu'ils
renfermaient solitaire silencieux très
difficile parce que je ne suis pas comme
les autres cantons et péter quand on est
enfant on veut être comme les autres
alors l'âge de 10 ans vous découvrez
chez des voisins avoue d'origine
finlandaise le finnois hélas si votre
début de l'exploration des langues
étrangères
aujourd'hui vous en maîtrisez une
dizaine alors l'anglais le finnois le
lituanien
l'espagnol le français l'allemand
l'islande est le roumain le gallois et
l'espéranto
vous avez créé votre propre langue le
même tee oui parce que quand on aime les
mots on veut jouer avec c'est une langue
où il ya beaucoup de voyages pas ce que
vous dites que c'est plus joli que les
consoles wii voit la santé c'était très
joli et ça donne je peux nous dire
bonjour je vais bien a menti par exemple
bva
coco tomita croteau vous êtes le seul à
parler cette langue oui
à l'adolescence vous découvrez la
fiction les romans le théâtre et surtout
shakespeare shakespeare est une
révélation pour vous parce que grâce à
shakespeare vous découvrez le langage
social c'est-à-dire l'empathie la
disputent l'amour la haine en fait
j'expire vous socialiste d'une certaine
exactement parce que pour la première
fois je comprends la de pouvoir de la
littérature en fait et puis shakespeare
il parlait énormément des mathématiques
louis parler surtout par exemple de
chiffre zéro parce qu'à l'époque de
shakespeare ça n'existait pas mais vous
dites c'est la première génération qui a
été élevé avec le chiffre zéro et là ça
n'existait pas avant lui alors toujours
parents adolescents s'amusaient beaucoup
avec les chiffres fait des
multiplications très complexe vous dites
d'ailleurs je ne calcule pas je vois le
résultat voilà en fait je ne suis
absolument pas un ordinateur ou
calculatrice j'ai du mal avec les choses
comme l'âge après tout ça puisque c'est
les choses qui sont pas tangibles est
pour moi c'est il faut toujours que ce
soit quelque chose d'humain ne construit
rien voilà alors vous faites aussi du
calcul calendaire alors je vais pas vous
considérez comme un singe savant elle
vous faire faire plein de trucs mais si
je vous dis le 6 janvier 1949 c'était
quelques jours c'était un jeudi bravo
c'est jour de ma naissance voilà alors
vous découvrez à ce moment là le nombre
pi alors le nombre pi bon bah on a tous
appris ça ses trois cannes pour nous ce
sata iii 14 14 116 vous vous décidez
d'apprendre le plus grand nombre de
décimales possible et le 3 mars
2004 vous en récit très des décimales du
nombre pi 22 1514 alors il a mis des
papiers sur les murs et ça et vous avez
photographié d'une certaine façon c'est
à dire vous pouvez en fait le nombre pi
pour moi c'est comme un poème numérique
au moins le nombre ça voulait dire
quelque chose chaque chiffre avait un
sens donc il fallait ça pour que j'entre
dedans et je vais aller dans un musée en
angleterre pour réciter ce nombre devant
un public et certains croient parce que
les gens il est absolument pas dans les
mathématiques adolescents des ouvriers
des gens de partout et en même temps et
c'était tellement touchée on donne la
récitation parfois même les gens qui
pleuraient et je me suis dit j'ai
compris en fait pro première fois que
j'avais ce don de passe un bandeau
compter mais de raconter pour vous c'est
un peu comme la joconde ou une symphonie
de mozart quand ça vient ça lui une
oeuvre d'art exactement vous réciter ses
22 1514 décimales sans faire une seule
erreur d'un véritable marathon vous
arrêtez de temps en temps mais à des
moments prédéfinis c'est à dire tous les
1000 chiffres vous arrêter pour manger
un carré de chocolat ou un fruit et
c'est tout quand vous allez aux
toilettes
alors vous accompagne pour être sûr que
vous parlez à personne donc c'est
vraiment fait pratiquement sous contrôle
d'huissier quoi mais oui exactement
c'était très puisque c'est un record
donc il fallait absolument que que ça
soit vérifié le défi suivant c'est
d'apprendre islande et en une semaine
c'est incroyable et vous l'avez fait un
jeu les faits je vais répondre une
semaine après une interview qui vous
étaient faites en islande et comme comme
on est en train de faire maintenant le
français gêné on veut en islande en
irlande et en islande et
une expérience encore une fois c'est le
sait les couleurs et tout ça à chaque
fois il y avait un sens j'ai essayé
d'associer les couleurs avec les
l'essence des démos et tout ça de créer
comme une toile d'araignée avec des
connexions d'aidé et c'était 1 c'était
très ludique c'était très et puisse à
chaque fois je j'ai eu vraiment du mal
en font
comprendre et à me communiquer que là
maintenant je suis à fond chez un fond
dans la communication ligaris mais je
vends
un génie il nous aura été donné de voir
un génie voilà au moins une fois dans
notre vie moi je croirai quand il
parlera le peuple en sept jours
il peut le faire
pascal
je pense à la musique évidemment mais je
pense à des gens que tu cites est tout à
l'heure comme comme mozart est ce que tu
as enfin
tu aime la musique est ce que tu a
imaginé mettre ça enfin tondon enfin ton
doux et chez clément pratique c'est ça
je suis en train d'écrire une chanson en
chanson juste le texte pour le projet
chanson
parce qu'il ya moyen d'écrire si si il
faut que vous m'appreniez et alors
attention
alors mozart et et asperger on pense
aujourd'hui non oui il ya un côté comme
ça il ya d avery a beaucoup de gens
ont dit peut-être einstein on vit
peut-être des certains poètes emmely
dickinson est très connue aux états unis
lluis carod un grand écrivain
mathématicien également
aspergé aussi on savait pas parce que le
mot n'existait pas oui à l'époque donc
et c'est très récent c'est très récent
et mais pour moi c'est très positif
parce que avant j'avais toujours le
sentiment que j'avais tort gt gt
paresseux pourquoi j'étais pas comme les
autres pourquoi les gens ne comprenaient
pas et là maintenant je vois que voilà
la différence s'est passé par handicap
merci beaucoup d'asnières passionnant
c'est génial merci
du conseil son bouquin voilà c'était
salut les terriens votre tour du samedi
avec pascal obispo l'alpa millésime est
dans les bacs il est en tournée dans
toute la france à partir de mars à
l'olympia 11 12 octobre et ce soir nous
sommes ensemble aux enfants de la télé
chez arthur voilà bruno le roux
président du groupe ps merci à
l'assemblée nationale at that you see
je grandis du lundi au vendredi à ranger
ses limites
jean daniel lévy de harris interactive
et gagne internet pour l'éternité dans
une heure aux arènes merci beaucoup
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission je vous laisse avec made
in groland et pour les abonnés à 20h55
le territoire lilou
avec la gamme nice rendez vous ici la
semaine prochaine et d'ici là sur
canalplus.fr avec en bonus le top des
bacs j'ai dit toute blague
vraiment les gaspard proust salut les
terriens
m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu